quando eu recebi o convite conforme para
pra falar no tempo foi foi algo
extraordinário não sei se eu consigo
alguma vez traduzir por palavras porque
em agosto deste ano foi convidado para
desenvolver uma uma fábrica no canal
televisivo para mim é novidade e depois
de ter feito a primeira intervenção eu
cheguei à escola tem uma escola do
método derose matosinhos e cheguei à
escola eles a equipa agora eu quero um
tempo eu quero te ver se há uns anos
atrás
a exposição em público gerava assinado
hoje em dia já em desvantagem é um
embuste para ir para frente e eu estou
eu quero ter em 2016 eu quero participar
do hotel e dois minutos depois ligaram
por caminhos cruzados acabaram por um
combinado e não emitem convidaram
consegue ver o cenário então eu comecei
a ver é o público conhecer o palco com
você ver a apresentação não tem a menor
idéia do que eu ia falar se a senhora
quer participar no pé não quer falar
sobre quem não segue e e consegue ver o
cenário e e conseguir trazer uma memória
a a ameo consciente quando o time não
vamos isso foi já na primavera de 54 foi
na primavera de 93 e e convidaram entre
aspas obrigaram porque não vamos nos
convidar ninguém ainda só tem tu vai tu
mesmo convidaram apresentar a festa
anual do colégio
vocês vão ver já participaram de uma
festa anual do colégio já desde os dois
anos de daloa até à quarta classe
então eram quatro ou cinco horas quando
eu tinha que apresentar a festa
eu tenho que apresentar todas as brigas
na e dança mímica teatro enfim tudo
aquilo com nove anos e para piorar tudo
irão para fazê lo com o novo amor de
infância toda a gente tem amor a
infância
então era uma menina loira lindíssima e
loja que eu carrego no meu coração
economizado muito profunda e convidaram
para fazer aquilo com ela portanto era
um duplo motivo para eu parar eu estava
super nervoso engasguei que brancas
enfim deve ter sido um desastre o
resultado é que deve ter sido um
desastre mas contém nove anos acho que
tem uma desculpa para poder sair dali
enfim com com sorriso e e esta ansiedade
é esta as suas emoções acelerado medo
culpa vergonha é a sensação de que não
somos oficiamos que não somos capazes
elas acompanham durante a nossa vida eu
gosto muito de uma frase do filme pessoa
que fez deus quer o homem sonha a obra
nasce
ian um grande problema é que por mais
que deus queira entre aspas por mais que
nós sonhamos por mais que nós queiramos
determinadas coisas quando nós no
momento decisivo não temos as emoções
certas coisas não funcionam porque nós
não conseguimos ter o que fazer com que
o cérebro na hora h disponibiliza todas
as ferramentas toda a criatividade ea
inteligência todo o brilho que nós temos
para fazer com que funcione ea e foi
durante muito tempo esta será a minha
acompanhou era na altura tornou-se um
moto pra minha vida do nosso motivo eu
quero fazer com que as pessoas tenham
emoções do zeramento poderosas
eu quero fazer com que as pessoas tenham
estado de performance para conseguir
realizar os seus sonhos e realizar os
seus propósitos
é isso que me move e esse contrato aqui
hoje
o que eu vou tentar ser explicados no
espaço bem curto porque faltam 15
minutos e isso é um trabalho de uma vida
é como é que nós podemos forma muito
simples transformar em funções deste
gênero desde que o livro que são
limitadoras para emoções que o facto nos
aumentem ou que levantem nossa
performance emoções como gratidão
contentamento otimismo e entusiasmo
nós percebemos como é que as coisas
funcionam em termos de resposta no nosso
organismo
a maior parte dos nossos pensamentos das
nossas emoções e dos nossos movimentos
corporais ea opção absolutamente
automáticos são reflexos ou
condicionados ou incondicionadas muito
raramente nós temos uma intervenção
confiante ou seja uma intervenção lúcida
sobre as nossas decisões durante o nosso
dia e se quiserem pensar sobre isso
procurem lembrar de quantas decisões
absolutamente divergentes vocês tiveram
no último ano
divergentes no sentido de ir serem
contrários às expectativas ou serem
contrários ao comportamento
a maior parte das nossas decisões são
espectáveis nós somos ser programados
condicionados e por isso mesmo as
respostas são esperadas desta forma é a
grande diferença entre os reflexos só
para não ficar em dúvida é com o reflexo
condicionado pretensa nossa biologia
por exemplo eu transfiro quanto calor e
ao seu livro quando o sintoma da comida
e e por isso nós partilhamos esses
reflexos já os condicionados e aos são
privados das nossas experiências dos
nosso nosso comportamento
então por exemplo é parente determinado
estímulo é para uma determinada situação
nós não podemos ter uma não resposta
se alguma coisa acontece na nossa vida e
nosso cérebro capta aquela informação ao
capital que o estimula a manter uma
resposta uma não resposta
imagine que a namorada perguntar
namorado acho que estou mais gorda e
silêncio de morte
não dá né então a única forma que eu
tinha de ganhar pontos não responder aos
tinham era evitar o estímulo é a única
forma de safáris e evitar a pergunta
para quando a pergunta foi feita acabou
não tem não tem forma de resolver e uma
não resposta a uma suposta não resposta
não fazer nada é muito pior
assis que estava gorda
o desgaste acabou legislação é então
este tipo de reflexo que nós temos por
exemplo no trânsito estamos a trabalhar
há anos atrasados temos um tempo contato
também com o trabalho
ao menos 12 no trânsito insulta nos
reagem da forma como sempre reagiram
vai ser sensacional quando mesmo com
razão nós possamos pedir desculpa e
sorrisos
ou seja ao invés de sermos uma mera
conseqüência daquilo que acontece com
carlos no lugar da causa e temos a
consciência de que a nossa resposta vai
influenciar o nosso lia e o dia daquelas
pessoas então não funcionam assim
basicamente nós raramente nos tornamos
observadores ou seja estamos conscientes
da do momento
quando eu comecei a praticar o método de
rose conseguiu descer com 17 anos eu
treinava muito praticava muito era pra
ser uma criança teria descoberto o
usuário não se não tem a menor idéia pra
mim aqui uma alegria do lugar mas de
facto fascinavam tanta prática eu senti
tanto prazer que consegui treinar muito
essencialmente técnicas respiratórias e
num determinado momento eu percebi que
eu saía de cena 16 jogos aconteceu estar
em uma discussão ou em algum hábito que
seja automático e saírem de cena e ao
mesmo tempo de dobrarem estarem a fazer
aquilo estarem se observar bem o que
fazer estou aqui viver então essas
instituições elas são subitamente
extraordinárias porque nesse momento ou
nós vamos ter uma maior capacidade de
mudar o curso natural das coisas é nesse
momento em que nós temos a oportunidade
de mudar a resposta e iniciar um novo
comportamento é uma inspiração tem esta
capacidade extraordinária a meu ver é
muito empírico porque ela está nos dois
mundos ela tanto pode ser absolutamente
inconsciente e ainda bem que isso
acontece
já hoje porque ela pode passar para um
patamar do consciente e começar a sentir
a minha inspiração
esta capacidade de nós sentimos a
inspiração entre frios num momento de
mudarmos os novos condicionamentos
desenvolve a nossa plasticidade mental
ou seja a capacidade que nós temos a
inovar senados 40 o mesmo estilo nós
temos uma resposta de entrar ao mesmo
proposta e produzir novos resultados e é
incrível efeito que isso tem na perceção
da realidade na obsessão da passagem do
tempo
vocês sabem que a medida que nós
vencemos e as pessoas com mais idade que
estou um pouco isso é preciso que o
tempo passa cada vez mais pressa
a culpa não é do tempo a culpa da
quantidade experiências novas que nós
deixamos de ter empresa quando nós
fazemos uma viagem e tem coisas novas a
língua e frango tem pessoas de frança em
arquitetura enfrenta gastronomia de
frente uma semana parece que há um ano
porque o cérebro está constantemente a
processar informações novas e isso
coloca dentro da experiência do retiro
nos automatismos
ainda assim nós não devemos valorizar os
nossos processos inconscientes os nossos
reflexos
o encontro tem coisas absolutamente
extraordinárias quando nós temos nós
tivéssemos que pensar na respiração ou
seja se nós fôssemos obrigados a
respirar de forma consciente seria um
desastre e eu freqüentemente em sines
aos meus alunos em algumas vezes têm
dificuldade
depois de tornar em inspiração
consciente deixarem a inspiração
aconteceu isso vai acontecer conosco
hoje vocês vão ter imensa desvinculado
embora e fazer com que a inspiração
funciona
se tiverem desenvolver um produto
incrível que um álbum pois vai estar à
venda
vocês colocam e é basicamente isso
inspira e podem andar com isso a vida
toda vai ensinar vocês vão sobreviver
nada mais vai acontecer
a inacreditável mas funciona se você
parar a 100
vocês parecem com esta imagem mas se não
é cra sons sem ser num écran que
acontecia
a inspiração inconsciente ela tem
vantagens inacreditáveis e uma delas e
acontece com todos os animais é fazer
com que o corpo possa transitar entre um
estado de absoluto repouso para o estado
de alerta
isso acontecia conosco nessa zona
africana acontece com os novos dados em
casa que estava descontraído repente por
um stylus ficam absolutamente estado
estão disponíveis com toda a força para
reagir
então se nós nos próximos com isto o
nosso cérebro e desligar um sem número
de funções que não são essenciais à
sobrevivência e com isso nós vamos
desligar a nossa solidariedade à nossa
lucidez
temos que tirar energia do nosso sistema
imunitário do nosso sistema digestivo
porque naquele momento isso não importa
é então isso tem a ver com um estímulo
do nosso sistema nervoso simpático pelo
impulso da sobrevivência coloque toda a
nossa energia em função de um processo
de luta ou fuga porque serve estão sendo
cavados eu vou ser morto
do nada no cérebro para que serve a
minha luz e ver se eu vou morrer agora
então o corpo que tira a energia de
todos os órgãos disponibilizadas para os
músicos
o coração acelera e aspiração acelera a
inspiração torna-se muito ofegante e com
isso nós conseguimos via para fugir eu
fugiria não sei que vocês faremos é uma
partida eu fuso né
o grande problema é quando esta lhe ou
essa vaga africana se transforma na
nossa namorada se transforma na pessoa
que use no trânsito se transforma no
nosso colega de trabalho se transforma
num funcionário do departamento das
finanças ou em qualquer outra coisa no
nosso dia a dia isso acontece quando nós
estimulamos o sistema simpático de forma
pontual é maravilhoso porque isso gera
um estímulo suficiente para que o corpo
se mantenha vivo em alerta da licht
estáveis enquanto uma coisa boa você
está vendo isso né
o grande problema é quando nós estamos
constantemente utilizar o estimular esse
sistema e roubar energy lucidez dos
outros
então para isso nós precisamos de
começar a trabalhar o nosso sistema
nervoso parassimpático para fazer com
que o sistema se você para a simpática
ela é responsável como contrapeso não é
eu tenho como características a
esperança mais lenta mais suave
batimentos cardíacos também mais mais
lentos e portanto em duas o corpo no
estado lançamento que compensa o outro
na natureza está muito simples o animal
e vai virar vai virar presa foge cob por
descansa e tá tudo resolvido na nossa
vida não é bem assim nós saímos de casa
com o estômago gorda vou atrasar o
trabalho já no buzinão chego já leva na
cabeça porque se atrasava enfim
e as coisas na verdade não tem uma
compensação é um dos exemplos em que
estes dois sistemas precisam funcionar
na perfeição e em equilíbrio é nossa
sexualidade e sim os outros estão a ter
mais confiança pra poder na guiné
estratégia mas no caso dos homens por
exemplo o sistema parassimpático
responsável pela ereção e os temas
empate que é responsável por nos
conduzir ao orgasmo
vocês vão ver o que acontece você vai
dizer lembrados né ou não acontece o
acontecido mais coisa não funciona
agora o pessoal já começar não deixou de
treinar dispensam então todos tocavam ou
irem para casa treinar isto grandes
amigos - bonobo não sei se vocês
conhecem mas os bonobos são uma espécie
manter e caupi prematuras são
provavelmente os mais próximos dos seres
humanos e alguns jovens tensões os
conflitos sociais de lula é chefe do
sistema simpático o sexo lerá então dois
indivíduos que tenhamos a matriarca do
grupo vai lá e com um contacto mais
limpo e em picos algumas coisas a fazer
quando inclusivamente a uma lenda do que
nós fomos a segunda opção para sermos
apenas na altura que a espécie estava
previsto ir primeiro consultar os
bonobos e olha vocês querem ser os
próximos chapas e descrever o que seria
o futuro deus enquanto a moça pensar em
deus a gente tá bem assim e ficaram
também não estou sujeito vocês resolvam
os conflitos no trânsito desta forma eu
acho que é e nem acreditava que os
alvinegros
vamos ouvir isso de forma agradável mas
de lá às vezes quando eu morava que a
paz assinará chito mais gorda o mec tem
que ser rápido
esperem um passinho num espaço sem falar
em estudo prevê a proposta de hoje e
isso não é em cima das outras -
obviamente mas é realmente o lugar dos
condicionamentos em três passos parar e
escolher ele começar vamos ter um
arquiteto da nossa própria vida como é
que isso funciona agora vai em todas as
nossas emoções todos os padrões
emocionais elas têm uma inspiração
específica
quando nós estamos ansiosos o quanto
estamos com medo ou quando estamos
excitados o quanto estamos entusiasmados
os apaixonados a nossa aspiração é que
uma freqüência amplitude e uma
velocidade muito característica daquela
emoção e isto serve para conseguirmos
produzir um estado biológico que
sustenta o movimento aquela emoção
a forma mais fácil de 9 sou vermos esta
energia resolvemos este padrão
respiratório é quebrar o padrão
respiratório aliás o que o padrão no
sinal é quebrar o padrão respiratório
então vamos convidar para fazer uma
inspiração muito profunda com estivesse
encher o balão e quiser se reinventar
como valão
isso vai conservar os pulmões podem
inspirar a vontade então inspire e
expire até o limite até não conseguir
mais colocar dentro dos pulmões
depois vai soltar o ar de forma muito
lenta e vai ficar sem ar enquanto puder
absolutamente sonhar quando precisava
respirar uma nova inspiração profunda
até o limite e vai voltar a ficar sem ar
o governo organizou já alguém na platéia
não vale a pena e até porque nós não sei
se temos aqui e me disponível não é por
aí que vocês vão voar vamos ver onde
isto vai parar no hospital
então tem que ser confortável nós vamos
inspirar forma muito profunda e o
terceiro e com isso nós vamos a partir
da neutralizar alguns estados emocionais
quando são estados mais fortes que
existem outras técnicas também poderosas
ou mais poderosas técnicas respiratórias
mas neste momento pelo menos tem essa
para cursar
depois nós neutralizar os emoções como
ansiedade medo nervosismo
nós precisamos mudar o registo no bar o
registro emocional
então que emoções no meu caso funcionam
emoções é que funciona para nos dar mais
reformas para nos colocar em um estava
em que nós por ciclos possibilita o
tempo de resposta
no meu caso as remoções de gratidão e é
muito fácil nós nos sentimos gratos
é muito fácil nós olharmos à nossa volta
e lembrarmos mil e uma coisas pelas
quais estamos gratos e se não fossem
todas elas gostariam simples fato de nós
estarmos vivos em segundo lugar instalar
um estado do contentamento
temos o privilégio de termos aquela
dificuldade temos aqui é um momento para
evoluir e não podemos nos superar
poderão chegar em último lugar o
entusiasmo
o entusiasmo é provavelmente uma das
emoções mais poderosas que consegue
cativar consegue projetar a nossa voz e
nossa mensagem para todos os outros e
consegue fazer com que nosso cérebro
tenha automaticamente disponível
todos os mortos todos assinados toda
criativada enfim
imagine o que o vosso cérebro brilhar e
com todas as faculdades para terem uma
performance incrível só com entusiasmo
que vão fazer e em último lugar a
começar ou seja depois de fazer a
interrupção da respiração
vamos começar a respirar os gregos
antigos de uma tenha um conhecimento
ensinamento muito interessante que dizia
que sempre que nós inspiramos confiança
ou cinco que inspiramos com inveja da
confiança nós enchemos de confiança e
nos inspiramos com ideia do entusiasmo
nos enchemos de entusiasmo
depois de neutralizar bem as emoções de
fazerem uma programação e instalarem
aquelas soluções que vão permitir uma
melhor performance de começar a respirar
forma lenta profunda e consciente
vocês vão encher-se de entusiasmo e vão
estar muito mais preparados para
qualquer tipo de desafio
eu gostaria que vocês com estas com
estas dicas com estas com esse
conhecimento deixassem de ser fruto das
consequências daquilo que nos acontece
durante o dia e fossem a origem das
coisas a causa das causas e pudessem ser
causa da nossa realidade passar sem ser
os arquitetos da nossa vida
muito obrigado